Oh
one when it first came out was a modest
hit critics seem to like it okay an
audience's seem to like it okay and even
today that seems to be the general
consensus people seem to like it okay
and yeah I guess I'm on the same boat
but I think I like it and dislike it for
different reasons everybody else does
what's the story a long time ago in
China we have the Huns invading so an
army has to be put together and one male
from every house has to go and fight the
only problem is the father of a teenage
girl named Mulan is too old and too sick
to fight so she disguises herself as a
boy and goes to fight for it she's
accompanied by a Chinese dragon played
by Eddie Murphy yeah it wasn't that
fitting casting and while she has a hard
time fitting in she does eventually win
over the crowd never letting on to her
secret okay so what do people in general
really like about this movie well they
like the girl power aspect they like the
fact that such a strong female lead that
she goes out she flings a sword she
fights her battles she does all this
good stuff and that'd be great
if she was a little bit more interesting
I don't want to say she's a bore cuz
she's not totally forgettable but again
I just feel like I've seen this
character before she's the free spirit
that everybody tells should be one thing
but she wants to be something else she
can't do the one thing that everybody
tells her to do so she wants to go into
something unconventional and when you
know it that unconventional thing
changes everybody's perception again not
a bad moral I've just seen it and her
character seems much more tied to the
moral than it does an actual character
well pulls her through are the scenes
where she's trying to be a boy but we'll
get to that in a second
people like Eddie Murphy as Mushu yeah I
don't he seemed really out of place I
didn't laugh that much Adam and I don't
know I didn't see a character I just saw
Eddie Murphy doing the voice of a
cartoon in something like Shrek it makes
a little bit more sense this is just the
kind of world it is in Chinese history
this doesn't seem to fly very well no to
be fair he does get a good line every
once in a while a couple of things I
know that bound to notice people like
the Chinese culture I think it's kind of
underplayed again is kind of like
Hercules just when you think Disney
animation is going to tackle this you
get really excited on what they
do and aside from a few backgrounds and
one or two designs it's pretty glanced
over I guess Chinese art in many ways
does celebrate the white space but I
think there's a better way to show it
off there's a lot of great Chinese art
and I'd like to see it explored more and
then of course you have the villain I'm
not sure if people like this guy or not
but in my opinion I think he is the most
forgettable villain ever put in Disney I
don't remember a thing about this guy
his design is boring his dialogue is
boring what he does is boring this is a
fierce warrior who burns down villages
and yet I can't remember one line out of
him the only thing I remember is that
the color in his eyes was reversed which
I didn't really get there's black where
the white should be and yellow where the
black should be and I don't know if
that's the most memorable thing about
him that's probably not a good sign
also I don't like the fact that the
ancient Chinese ancestors again giving
some kids have real culture into this
history is done more like a meeting at
the old folks home I mean I know it's
supposed to be played for last but I
just didn't find that funny again when
you think Disney animation and Chinese
goes you think of something really
spectacular but this just seems like a
throwaway bitching mom bitching mom what
do I like about this movie honestly I
like the comedy I know it sounds weird
seeing how he just bashed Eddie Murphy
and the ancestor ghost people but I like
everything else I like the side
characters I like this army
I like how they poked fun of gender
roles I like her attempts of trying to
fit in I like everybody trying to act
tough but failing miserably for me the
side characters is what makes this movie
particularly the army themselves I love
these guys I love the guy who's prone to
anger I love the one who's kind of a
pacifist I love the other one who's kind
of a show-off
I love the pencil pusher that everybody
makes fun of and like I said when Mulan
tries to blend in it's really hilarious
I actually think there's a lot of
subtlety to this humor too
like have you ever noticed when the one
guy wanted to shake hands she
accidentally hands it to him like she's
expecting him to kiss it that's really
kind of subtle plus the comedic
expressions are great and just how quick
they are oh hi guys I didn't know you
were here I was just washing so now I'm
clean and I'm gonna go bye-bye though at
times I have to admit some of the gender
issues get a little too weird like when
all the guys are whistling at the women
in the fields and then Millan tries to
cover her face while they laugh no is
that a little too odd maybe I'm just
over it
for the most part their play pretty
funny but again it's not just the comedy
that makes me enjoy it
it's the army in general I like the
camaraderie I like the individuals I
like that they try to work with one
another I like that they anger each
other I like that they make each other
laugh and I like Mulan trying to blend
in with them for me that's where the
heart of the movie is so like I said
before I think it's okay it's certainly
not one of the stronger Disney films and
I think it certainly could have been a
lot more but for what it is it's got
some good scenes I remember liking it
enough that I did sit down to watch it
again which is more than I can say for
some of the other Disney films I think
are merely okay so in my opinion it's
worth at least one viewing I wouldn't
expect a whole lot of culture but I
would expect just the right amount of
entertainment
inside